cierra la vuelta el delito de ayudar en
una decisión sin precedentes el gobierno
de Daniel Ortega canceló la personería
jurídica de la Cruz Roja en Nicaragua
argumentando que la organización
humanitaria incumplió las leyes del país
pero opositores y expertos afirman que
se trata de represalia por la atención
que brindó la institución a cientos de
heridos que dejó la represión a las
protestas anti gubernamentales de 2018
dos actos acontecidos del año 2018 que
atentaron contra la paz y estabilidad de
la nación
algunas filiales de esta asociación
actuaron en contra de Estos principios y
de su acta
constitutiva y estatuto y la asociación
misma transgredió las leyes del país al
desentenderse y hasta apoyar este actuar
de sus filiales con la decisión de
Cancelar sus operaciones y confiscar sus
bienes se pierden decenas de proyectos
sociales y atención médica que realizaba
en el país argumentando respetar los
convenios de Ginebra de 1949 los
diputados anunciaron la creación de la
Cruz Roja nicaragüense convirtiendo a la
organización sin fines de lucro en un
ente adscrito al Ministerio de salud
todo
patrimonio
bienes y acciones que a la fecha
pertenezcan a la asociación nacional
llamada Cruz Roja nicaragüense
pasarán a ser propiedad del Estado
la Cruz Roja Internacional intentó
mediar en la crisis sociopolítica de
Nicaragua Pero el gobierno negó misiones
humanitarias como visitar a los
prisioneros políticos la asociación
ahora se suma a más de tres mil ongs que
han sido suspendidas en el país
centroamericano desde 2018